final game of a three-game series in
seattle for the houston astros and they
have zach granky their ace on the mound
going kyle lewis steps in 10th of the
american league get on base percentage
on the ground bregman able to smother it
stays with it and
not in time lewis gets aboard infield
base hit for kyle lewis here is kyle
seeger in right field kyle seeger gets
the base it is kyle lewis motors quickly
into third of the mariners have runners
on the corners great opportunity for ty
france to drive in a run first and third
just the one out
ragman can't make the catch it's a fair
ball and into left field kyle lewis is
scoring here comes seeger into third
base
he slides in ty france a run scoring
double
and france able to keep his hands back
just long enough and barely a fair ball
that'll work and a little discussion
with the home plate umpire marvin hudson
the crew chief
as martine walked to the mound and zach
walked to the plate well you know what
it is runner at third base he told him
he's going to pitch out of the stretch i
think looks like he's mounting something
to maldonado
three and one to count
there you go
we're on the same page now
fly ball
not too deep and left
seeger at third will bluff ago as
brantley's throw comes home that's a big
out for zach
marmalejos pops out to shallow low
four pitch walk
we already had a visit from maldonado
where greinke blew him off and now
you've got stromi coming out there to
have him
hopefully a little more extensive
conversation
so evan white will be the hitter
swinging a miss got him
swinging for the final out
zach cranky picks up his first strikeout
and strands of basically
i think mark gavitz with a 2-2 count to
euleg ariel to start the fifth and euler
hits a line drive to center field that's
the old swing we like to see from julie
guriel
he's now three for four against
margavitches in his career with a
leadoff single here in the field see if
the astros could take advantage of their
third leadoff runner on in the last five
innings now they have two on with nobody
out as correa picks on the first pitch
and grounds a single to left field
guriel and correa back-to-back singles
martine who has drawn more walks than
any astro 24 will be very selective here
you would think on a 3-0 pitch
and that's outside ball four that'll
load them up for george springer with
one out in the inning the o2
he got him on three pitches
[Applause]
two down now touveo for two margavitches
to pitch away from sending this one to
the bottom of the fifth
kyle lewis easily glides back in front
of the track and nick margavitches gets
out of a bases loaded jam he leaves him
loaded to take us to the home finn
up the middle into center field for base
hit
two outs
seeger
clubbed out to the gap this is sucked on
its way back and off the wall
crawford flying around he hits the bag
at third correa's throw home play at the
blake he is safe
two nothing mariners kyle seeger with
his second base hit today
watching crawford right there
he hit every base perfectly you can't
cut the corners any better than he did
obviously he was flying around the bases
and he needed to be because it was a
perfect relay by houston that was as
good as you can get
here's ty friends
clubbed out to left bradley won't be
able to get to it seeger is on his way
home
kyle seeger scores from second with ease
ty france with his second rbi today it's
three nothing mariners at the bottom of
the fifth marmalados
on the ground and
france having to skip a little rope he
makes his way onto third
and the inning continues
that's to be the last batter zach
frankie will face
dusty baker comes out and gets the
baseball andre scrub will be the new
pitcher
now tip caught by maldonado that'll end
the inning andre scrub doing a good job
stranding runners
game stays three nothing seattle tying
run at the plate the 2-2
drops the hammer on him
bregman caught looking missevich strands
of pair the mariners still in front two
outs
last hope for the astros elena's diaz
seeger can't get to it
tucker
rounding second moving to third
diaz stands up he's got his second
double today reddick the tying run at
the plate with two outs of the night
that ball is a line drive base hit it to
center field astros are going to get two
runs josh redick just like he did on
monday night spoils the shutout with two
outs of the ninth and the astros now
down three to two reddick will leave the
game with miles straw now at first base
as a tying run so still no shutouts for
the mariners in 2020 they've come within
and out twice in this series but still a
threat with the tying run at second in
the go ahead at first the 1-2 he got him
swinging and the ball game is over
mariners win it they win the series and
a nice way to go out on the home
schedule in 2020